Next question, David.
I see that Joe Biden is doing really well
in the polls.
What is the point of no return for Donald
Trump's polling?
So let me first give you.
For practical purposes.
Answer.
Imagine.
There is no point of no return.
Even if Trump is losing by 20.
On November 2nd, you go out and you vote on
November 3rd because you just don't know what's
going to happen in your state.
We all have to vote, et cetera.
Now.
I believe that if on October 1st, about a
month before the election, the numbers are
what they are today.
I believe it's it's over for Donald Trump.
Short of a true miracle.
We're not talking.
Think back to 2016.
2016, heading into election, into the election
day.
The national polling was Hillary is up by
three point two.
And Hillary won by two point one in the national
popular vote, of course, because of 77000
votes in three states.
Electorally, she ultimately lost.
We're talking about, you know, an eight to
nine point lead for Joe Biden right now.
And if those are the numbers going into the
election, Joe Biden is is going to win.
Now, what could change this?
Listen, if Joe Biden's indicted between now
and November, if Joe Biden dies between now
and November, if Trump personally cures cancer
on Halloween, writes it.
These are the types of things where if on
October 1st, Biden's up eight and a half.
That's what you need to turn it around.
William Barr and Mitch McConnell could try
to pull something underhanded, you know, maybe
some kind of B.S. investigation into Joe or
Hunter Biden.
Maybe it would have an impact.
Honestly, at this point, I don't even know
that that would make a difference.
A lot of people would not take it seriously.
You know, Trump's retweeting Chuck Woolery
while attacking Anthony Foushee on the issue
of Corona virus.
It's clear that Trump has lost credibility
with a large swath of the American electorate
each day that Trump doesn't take the lead
in the polling.
It's a day he loses to turn it around.
And, you know, I've been getting e-mails about
should Joe Biden even bother to debate Trump?
The idea now being.
Trump's doing so much self-inflicted damage.
Why would Joe Biden even come out and debate?
Now, of course, your view on that depends
on how well you think Joe Biden would do.
I hope they debate.
I look forward to watching the debates, but
I do think there's a question there.
Like, is it easy to just let Trump continue
to self-destruct?
Maybe debating him doesn't even really make
sense.
Although, again, if Trump is willing and Biden
is not, it would look bad for Joe Biden.
The other difference, I think that's important
in terms of looking at the polling in 2016
and looking at the polling today, is that
in 2016, Donald Trump was running on being
the anti Washington, D.C. guy.
He was riding a wave of and tie establishment
sentiment, which may have helped him as Hillary
Clinton was dogged by the James Comey press
conference, et cetera.
Trump is the establishment right now.
So that is not going to work.
And in terms of looking at why Trump isn't
doing well in the polls, the leading drag
factors for Trump are corona virus handling
economy, racial issues as connected to the
George Floyd protests.
Could those changed between now and November?
Yeah, theoretically.
I mean, Corona virus could be gotten more
under control right now.
It says out of control, as it's been.
If that were to happen, the economy could
start to turn around.
Three and a half months is not that long.
And we've already been in corona virus mode
for about five months.
So how likely that is is a question mark.
But I would see the potent point of no return
as sometime around October 1st, barring something
earth shattering, earth shattering, like an
indictment of Joe Biden.
Or again, as I said, Trump personally cures
cancer or develops a corona virus vaccine.